[Music]
nick is with us in salt lake city hi
nick how are you
good how are you guys doing better than
we deserve what's up
so i just had a quick question for you
guys so
uh we have an opportunity you know wife
to buy a house
but the problem is that it's a million
dollar house
but it has two rental properties inside
the house
that would bring in around five grand a
month
and so the mortgage would only be around
four thousand dollars a month
and we could make potentially around
five do you think that would be a smart
decision to do to buy that house not if
you're dependent on the rent to pay the
bill
okay
let me tell you what justin i don't know
where i don't know where you were in the
last three years
but in some areas
rent uh you couldn't evict someone for
not paying for six months because the
pandemic yeah during which time you
would have been foreclosed on sir
yeah so the the thing is though is that
you drove right past that and didn't
hear a dadgum thing i said
i did but um i'm just curious because
we're
i don't know we feel pressured to do it
from certain people but we're kind of
hesitant the thing is though that it's
not like a typical rental it's airbnb's
and they have three years that's even
worse you're attracted three where
they're bringing out that's even worse
because now we've got cities passing
laws not allowing airbnb because they're
in violation of zoning
okay why were you hesitant you just
nailed the whole thing you're feeling
pressure from some people that you and
your wife respect big time they have a
lot of influence over you and yet you're
hesitant what are you hesitant about
um just i think it
seems like a good opportunity but also i
don't know if we can make it work yeah i
think there's a lot more risks here than
the people pressuring you have any
concept of that's right they don't know
what the flip they're talking about
so no i'm not going to tell you to do
this deal based on this i think you're
doing i think you're going to get
yourself in trouble
uh and on top of that
you're living in a house with other
people
uh
kind of defeats the purpose man
if i want to live in a hotel i'd buy a
hotel
ugh
no thank you
um
just you know all in the name i can make
a buck on the name of all real estate's
a good investment all real estate's not
a good investment
real estate is a good investment all
education is not a good investment
education
is a good investment but there are
stupid forms of real estate and stupid
forms of education
i mean you can get a degree in german
polka history or medieval left-handed
puppetry but that doesn't mean you're
gonna end up being anything but a
barista
and that you know that's stupid
education and when you buy real estate
leveraged up to your eyeballs and you
say well the renters are going to pay
the rent that's stupid
because i've had renters for 30 years
let me just tell you some of them don't
pay sometimes they go in chapter 13
bankruptcy there's a pandemic moratorium
on for on evictions and you're sitting
on them
and uh you know had nothing to do with
the pandemic they just chose to not pay
because the government told them they
could and then when you do finally get
them out they've oh can you tell i'm
bitter well you got to be aware of the
influence trap what you just heard folks
happens to all of us at some point in
our lives if we're not careful and
people that we respect and love dearly
that are stupid who yes but yet they
tell us it's a good idea and something
in our guts this young man he said we're
hesitant about it he didn't feel right
about it but the influence of people who
have no idea what they're talking about
makes him think well gee whiz they said
it's a good idea maybe i should consider
it thankfully he called the show today
read some articles about what's
happening to airbnb politically in a
whole bunch of markets
they're getting their face smacked man
and their hands and everything else
smacked
and so you can re you build your whole
pro forma based on airbnb performance
you can really get yourself in a crack
dude
don't do it don't do it